PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS SO WE GET
STARTED [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
THE HOUR OF TWELVE NOON HAVING
ARRIVE.
AND PURSUANT TO THE CONSTITUTION
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE ORGANIZATIONAL SESSION FOR
THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY
REGULAR SESSION OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY.
IS NOW IN ORDER AYE ME DOTSON
WILSON CHIEF CLERK IN
PARLIAMENTARIAN.
AND PURSUANT TO THE GOVERNMENT
CODE I WILL BE PRESIDING OVER
THIS PORTION OF THE SESSION
UNTIL A SPEAKER IS ELECTED. ONE
HOUSEKEEPING MATTER.
PURSUANT TO THE ASSEMBLY RULES
PLEASE TURN OFF ALL CELL PHONES
IN ELECTRONICS ELECTRONIC
DEVICES.
DURING TODAY'S SESSION.
WE WILL ALSO BE FOR HER THE
INTRODUCTION OF GUESTS UNTIL
AFTER THE ELECTION OF A SPEAKER.
THE FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS IS
THE ROLL CALL.
OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS A LET.
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
ARAMBULA.
OUR QUE HAN [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
BURNER HORVATH [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
CERVANTES [inaudible]
CHAU [inaudible]
CAN [inaudible]
DAVID CHIU [inaudible]
CHOI A KANSEN CHU [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible] EIGHT MEN
[inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GABRIEL [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
CRISTINA GARCIA [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
GONZALEZ IS [inaudible]
GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON HOLDEN --
WHEN [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LEVINE LIMóN OWN [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
MAYES [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
MELENDEZ [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI.
THEN IS THERE IN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
PEACHTREE NORRIS [inaudible]
QUIRK [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
RAMEAU'S RENDON [inaudible]
RAY IS --
THREE OF US [inaudible]
ROBERT REAVIS [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SMITH STONE [inaudible]
TING [inaudible]
VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WAKES [inaudible]
WOULD.
THANK YOU MADAM CLERK.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION A REQUEST
FROM THE HONORABLE ANTHONY
RENDON. TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR AND
IN THE GALLERY SHALL BE GRANTED.
THE NEXT ORDER OF BUSINESS IS
THE PRAYER IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE.
WOULD YOU PLEASE STAND.
THIS AFTERNOON'S PRAYER.
WILL BE OFFERED BY THE HONOR
ROLL SHIRLEY WEBER.
DOCTOR WEBER.
LET US PRAY.
FATHER WE COME TODAY ON THIS
IMPORTANT OCCASION --
THANK YOU FOR THE BLESSINGS OF
AMERICA.
WHERE EVER MINDFUL THAT DESPITE
OUR MANY FLAWS?
IN THE IN PERFECT UNION IN WHICH
WE LIVE.
THERE'S STILL MUCH TO BE
THANKFUL AND PROUD.
FATHER THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
HAVE SPOKEN.
AND SHOWS IN THE EIGHTY MEMBERS
IN THIS CHAMBER TO REPRESENT THE
WISHES. TO PROTECT THE STATE. TO
SECURE THE FUTURE OF THEIR
CHILDREN.
AND TO SAFEGUARD THIS DEMOCRACY
FROM TYRANNY WITHIN AND WITHOUT.
CALIFORNIA HAS EXPRESS THEIR
BELIEFS AND THE STRENGTH OF OUR
DIVERSITY.
A UNITED CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS A MOMENTOUS OCCASION.
AND A GREAT OCCASION FOR MUCH
CELEBRATION.
HOWEVER IN THE MIDST OF THIS
WE MUST NOT FORGET THE THOUSANDS
WHO HAVE LOST THEIR HOMES AND
LIVES IN FIRES AND WOOD INFLUX
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
LET US NOT FORGET THAT THERE IS
A GROWING VIOLENCE IN THE STATE
AND IN THIS NATION THAT WE MUST
ADDRESS.
LET US NOT FORGET THOSE WHO ARE
WITHOUT SHELTER AND FOOD.
AND LET'S NOT FORGET THE
THOUSANDS AT OUR BORDERS SEEKING
A BETTER LIFE AS MANY OF US DID
NOT SO LONG AGO.
LET'S NOT FORGET THE MILLIONS OF
CHILDREN SITTING IN OUR
CLASSROOMS EXPECTING A WORLD
CLASS EDUCATION.
ONLY TO BE DISAPPOINTED AND
UNPREPARED FOR A BRIGHTER FUTURE.
FATHER LET US NOT FORGET THE
FAMILIES WHO ARE HURTING FROM
THE DEATH OF THEIR LOVED ONES
WILL ON ARMED.
FATHER THE CITIZENS OF THE STATE
HAVE ENTRUSTED US TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES AND MANY MORE ON
THEIR BEHALF.
AND WE KNOW THAT IF WE HOLD ON
TO WHAT YOU TAUGHT US EARLY IN
SUNDAY SCHOOL. TO DO WANT OTHERS
AS YOU WOULD HAVE US DO ONE TO
THEM.
BUT THE COURAGE TO STAND FOR
WHAT IS RIGHT AND JUST.
WE WILL NOT DISAPPOINT THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE FATHER LET US NOT BETRAYED
HIS TRUST THAT THEY HAVE
BESTOWED UPON US.
GIVE US THE WISDOM TO UNDERSTAND
THE IMPORTANCE OF OUR PLACE IN
HISTORY.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY THE COURAGE
TO STAND FOR THOSE PRINCIPLES
THAT CONTINUE TO BUILD UPON OUR
LEGACY OF INCLUSION.
RESPECT HOPE AND LOVE.
THAT IS DEDICATED SWEARING INTO
THOSE WHO PUT THEIR TRUST AND
FAITH IN US. FOR THE FUTURE OF
OUR STATE IS IN OUR HANDS.
WE PRAY THAT THEY WILL NOT
REGRET THE DECISIONS THEY MADE
ON TO STEP ON NOVEMBER.
SIX BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY WITH
THANK GOD FOR ALL OF US.
AND LET THE PEOPLE SAY A MAN.
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING THANK YOU
DOCTOR WEBER.
THE NEXT ORDER OF BUSINESS IS
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO OUR
FLAG.
THE HONORABLE TODD GLORIA.
WILL LEAD US IN THE PLEDGE.
PLEASE SPACE THE FLAG PLACE YOUR
RIGHT HAND OVER YOUR HEART READY
BEGAN [inaudible]
CLASS [inaudible]
ISRAEL.
PLEASE BE SEATED THANK YOU
MISTER GLORIA
.
MOVING ON WITH TODAY'S BUSINESS.
LEAVES OF ABSENCES FOR THE DAY.
THE LEAVES OF ABSENCES WILL BE
PRINTED IN THE DARLING DAILY
JOURNAL.
THE NEXT ORDER OF BUSINESS IS
THE CERTIFICATE OF ELECTION FROM
THE SECRETARY OF STATE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
CERTIFICATE OF ELECTION FROM THE
SECRETARY OF STATE DESIGNATING
THE DULY ELECTED MEMBERS FOR
THIS SESSION.
SHALL BE PRINTED IN THE DAILY
JOURNAL.
THE NEXT ORDER OF BUSINESS IS
THE ADMINISTERING OF THE OATH OF
OFFICE TO THE MEMBERS ELECT.
THE PROCESS FOR ADMINISTERING
THE OATH IS REFERRED TO AS THE
ROLE BY COUNTIES AND IT DATES
BACK.
TO EIGHTEEN FIFTY TWO THE
PROCESS OPERATES AS FOLLOWS THE
READING CLERK WILL READ A LIST
OF ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES IN
ALPHABETICAL ORDER.
AS THE NAME OF THE COUNTY OR
COUNTIES YOU REPRESENT IS CALLED.
YOU SHOULD STAND AND REMAIN
STANDING.
THE OATH OF OFFICE WILL BE
ADMINISTERED SIMULTANEOUSLY TO
ALL EIGHTY MEMBERS BY THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL
HOBBY ERR BUT SERRA.
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL BY
COUNTIES [inaudible]
ALAMEDA [inaudible]
ALPINE [inaudible]
AMADOR [inaudible]
VIEW [inaudible]
CALAVERAS [inaudible]
COLUSA [inaudible]
CONTRA COSTA [inaudible]
STILL NOR [inaudible]
EL DORADO [inaudible]
FRESNO [inaudible]
PLAN [inaudible]
HUMBOLDT [inaudible]
IMPERIAL [inaudible]
INYO [inaudible]
KERN [inaudible]
KINGS [inaudible]
LAKE [inaudible]
LASSEN [inaudible]
LOS ANGELES [inaudible]
MADERA [inaudible]
MARIN [inaudible]
MARIPOSA [inaudible]
MENDOCINO [inaudible]
MERCED [inaudible]
MODOC [inaudible]
MYT NO [inaudible]
MONTEREY [inaudible]
NAPA [inaudible]
NEVADA [inaudible]
ORANGE [inaudible]
FASTER [inaudible]
LOOMIS [inaudible]
RIVERSIDE [inaudible]
SACRAMENTO [inaudible]
SAN BENITO [inaudible]
SAN BERNARDINO [inaudible]
SAN DIEGO [inaudible]
SAN FRANCISCO [inaudible]
SAN JOAQUIN.
SAN LUIS OBISPO [inaudible]
SAN MATTEO [inaudible]
SANTA BARBARA [inaudible]
SANTA CLARA [inaudible]
SANTA CRUZ [inaudible]
SHASTA [inaudible]
SIERRA [inaudible]
SISKIYOU [inaudible]
SOLANO [inaudible]
CINEMA [inaudible]
STANISLAUS [inaudible]
SUTTER [inaudible] TO HEMA
[inaudible]
TRINITY [inaudible]
TELL [inaudible]
SWALLOW ME [inaudible]
VENTURA [inaudible]
YOLO [inaudible]
YUBA.
THANK YOU MADAM CLERK WILL ASK
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HOBBY ERR
Và SERRA. TO COME FORWARD TO
ADMINISTER THE OATH OF OFFICE.
I WOULD ASK EACH AND EVERYONE OF
YOU TO RAISE YOUR RIGHT HAND.
AND REPEAT AFTER ME.
I STATE YOUR NAME.
DO SOLEMNLY SWEAR.
THAT I WILL SUPPORT AND DEFEND.
THE CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES.
AND THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
THEY ARE.
IT'S ALL ENEMIES FOREIGN AND
DOMESTIC [inaudible] FOR THAT I
WILL BEAR. EIGHTY TO FAITH AND
ALLEGIANCE. TO THE CONSTITUTION
OF THE UNITED STATES.
AND THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT I TAKE THIS OBLIGATION
FREELY.
WITHOUT ANY MENTAL RESERVATION.
FOR PURPOSES OF ASIAN.
AND THAT I WILL WELL AND
FAITHFULLY.
DESTRUCTIVE DUTIES.
ARE -- WHICH
I'M ABOUT TO ENTER.
CONGRATULATIONS
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
I CONGRATULATIONS MEMBERS
.
THE SEARCH SERGEANT AT ARMS IS
IN THE PROCESS OF CIRCULATING
THE OATH OF OFFICE. FOR THE
SIGNATURE.
OF THE NEWLY SWORN MEMBERS.
CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK YOU
ATTORNEY GENERAL BUT SERRA.
PLEASE BE SEATED.
THE NEXT ORDER OF BUSINESS.
IS THE NOMINATION AND ELECTION
OF A SPEAKER OF THE ASSEMBLY.
FOR THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
TWENTY REGULAR SESSION.
NOMINATIONS FOR THE OFFICE OF
SPEAKER ARE NOW OPEN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRI NORTH FOR
WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU RIDE.
AT THE ASSEMBLY [inaudible]
ON YOU MAY OPEN ON YOUR
NOMINATION [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WE HAVE.
EACH AND EVERYONE OF US WE HAVE
BEEN GIVEN A TRULY EXTRAORDINARY
OPPORTUNITY. TO SERVE THE GREAT
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. TO SHAPE
THE FUTURE OF THE WORLD'S.
LARGEST ECONOMY.
AND TO TOUCH THE LIVES OF MORE
THAN FORTY MILLION CALIFORNIANS
[inaudible]
TRULY EXTRAORDINARY.
I HAVE TO SAY AS A NEW MEMBER
JOINING THIS A GAS INSTITUTION I
WASN'T ENTIRELY SURE WHAT TO
EXPECT WAS A ONE THREE NINE TWO
A SET PIECES FROM HOUSE OF CARDS
OR V. OR GAME OF THRONES.
AND HAPPILY NO NONE OF THE ABOVE.
WHAT I'VE ALREADY LEARNED IS
THAT THE PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM AND
THE PEOPLE IN THIS BUILDING?
ARE FOCUSED ON SUBSTANCE FOCUSED
ON CONFRONTING THE REAL ISSUES
AND FOCUSED ON FOURTEEN REAL
SOLUTIONS WE WORK ACROSS PARTY
LINES AND ACROSS DISTRICT
BOUNDARIES TO GET THINGS DONE
FOR THE PEOPLE.
WHO ELECTED*?
AND YOU KNOW I THINK THAT THAT
TONE.
COMES FROM THE VERY TOP.
THAT COLLEGIALITY THAT FOCUS ON
PRODUCTIVITY THAT FOCUSED ON
GOOD WORKS THAT COMES FROM OUR
LEADERSHIP.
DOESN'T MEAN DOLLAR SAID A GOOD
HEAD AND A GOOD HEART ARE A
FORMIDABLE COMBINATION.
AND OUR LEADER ANTHONY RENDON
CERTAINLY POSSESSES BUT MANY OF
YOU KNOW HE'S BEEN AN EDUCATOR
HE'S BEEN THE NONPROFIT DIRECTOR
HE'S BEEN ENVIRONMENTAL ACTIVIST
HERE IN THE ASSEMBLY HE HAS
PRESIDED OVER SOME OF THE MOST
PROGRESSIVE.
AND PRODUCTIVE LEGISLATIVE
SESSIONS IN MEMORY.
PASSING A LANDMARK FIFTY TWO
BILLION DOLLAR TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING PLAN.
EXTENDING CALIFORNIA'S CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM AND PROTECTING OUR
COASTLINE FROM OFFSHORE DRILLING.
HE'S CONFRONTED OUR FORMAL
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS CRISIS.
SPEAR HEADING FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGET FOR HOMELESSNESS
AND UNDER THE SPEAKERS
LEADERSHIP ARE THE NUMBER OF
WOMEN IN THE ASSEMBLY HAS GROWN
FROM. EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY THREE
INCLUDING [inaudible]
INCLUDING.
WOMEN WERE ELECTED WITH ME IN
THE CLASS OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN SO
WE HAVE MUCH MORE WORK TO DO ON
THAT FRONT ITS WORK I KNEW THAT
HE IS COMMITTED TO DOING.
THIS IS A MAN WHO PUTS PEOPLE
BEFORE POLITICS WHO PUTS GOOD
WORKS BEFORE GRANDSTANDING.
ALSO HAPPENS TO BE A MAN WHO
KNOWS THE BEST PLACE FOR GOOD
FUSION BRANCH FOR A. B.
VIETNAMESE MILKSHAKE IN
VIRTUALLY EVERY CORNER OF THE
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO WHILE I SUSPECT THAT YOUR
INTEREST IN MY RACE MAY HAVE HAD
SOMETHING AT FIRST TO DO WITH
DISCOVERY NOT LITTLE MILKSHAKE
PLACE IN COSTA MESA.
CERTAINLY GREW FROM THERE.
THANK YOU FOR BELIEVING IN ME
THANK YOU FOR MAKING THIS A
REALITY THANK YOU FOR INSPIRING
AND EMPOWERING SO MANY OF US.
IT IS MY HONOR AND PRIVILEGE TO
SERVE ALONGSIDE YOU AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN FRIENDS AND
COLLEAGUES IT IS MY HONOR AND
PRIVILEGE TO NOMINATE TO THE
OFFICE OF SPEAKER THE ASSEMBLY.
OUR LEADER MISTER ANTHONY RENDON.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRI
NORTH.
IS THERE A SECOND TO THE
NOMINATION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES WHAT
PURPOSE THE RICE.
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO SECOND THE
NOMINATION OF MY FRIEND ANTHONY
RENDON. TO CONTINUE ON AS
SPEAKER OF OUR ASSEMBLY.
I KNOW MANY OF YOU WILL SPEAK TO
WHAT THIS HOUSE HAS ACHIEVED
WHAT WE WILL ACHIEVE IN THE
FUTURE UNDER OF SPEAKER RENDON
LEADERSHIP.
HOWEVER TO ME.
THIS FACT STANDS OUT.
OR DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS NOW
INCLUDES TWENTY ONE WOMEN.
WHICH MATCHES THE HISTORICAL
RECORD FOR THIS LEGISLATURE.
INDEED THE NUMBER OF DEMOCRATIC
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS HAS DOUBLED UNDER
SPEAKER RENDON'S TEN YEAR.
NOW MORE THAN EVER TO SPEAKERS
COMMITMENT TO EMPOWERING THE
VOICES OF WOMEN BOTH IN THE
LEGISLATURE.
AND ACROSS OUR STATE IS BOTH
ENCOURAGING AND NECESSARY.
IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO KNOW.
THE DEATH A SPEAKER RENDON'S
COMMITMENT THIS VERY BODY.
JUST THIS FALL HE SPENT SEVERAL
HOURS IN THE WHAT THE SWAT
TREATING INLAND EMPIRE HEAT.
KNOCKING ON DOORS WITH ME TO
TALK TO VOTERS IN THE DISTRICT
THAT I REPRESENT.
OTHER LEADERS MAY NOT HAVE GONE
TO SUCH GREAT LENGTHS.
MAYBE POSTED ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
GOT A PHOTO WALK.
AND GOING ON THEIR WAY.
BUT ANY RENDON IS A KIND OF
SPEAKER WHO IS NOT AFRAID TO
ROLL UP HIS SLEEVES AND DO WHAT
IS NECESSARY TO CONTINUE GETTING
THINGS DONE FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THAT IS WHY COLLEAGUES IT IS AN
HONOR TO SECOND THE NOMINATION
FOR AND YOU ANTHONY RENDON TO
CONTINUE AS OUR SPEAKER.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES. TO SECOND THE
NOMINATION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS I AM PROUD TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF ANTHONY RENDON ON WHO
I NOT ONLY CONSIDER A FRIEND BUT
A GREAT LEADER.
MISTER RENDER ON HAS SPENT MANY
YEARS IN EDUCATION AND AS AN
EDUCATOR MYSELF FOR THIRTY YEARS
WE HAVE MUCH IN COMMON.
THE ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I NOT
ONLY KNEW ABOUT HIM BUT I HAVE
SEEN EXECUTED IN HIS LEADERSHIP
IS IS DEVOTION TO EARLY
CHILDHOOD.
HE IN HIS PAST WITH THE LEADER
IN EARLY CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT
IN ADDITION TO THAT HE ALSO HAS
SUPPORTED HEALTHY START PROGRAMS
EVEN START PROGRAMS EARLY START
PROGRAMS --
WHICH HE IS THE SUGGESTION THAT
WHEN WE INVEST IN OUR CHILDREN.
AS YOUNGSTERS WE KNOW THAT THEY
HAVE A PATH FORWARD. ONE N!N
NELSON MANDELA ONCE SAID.
THERE CAN BE NO KEENER
REVELATION OF A SOCIETY'S SOUL
THAN THE WAY IN WHICH IT TREATS
ITS CHILDREN.
THIS SENTIMENT READINGS AS TRUE
TO ME AS I KNOW IT DOES WITH HIM.
IS A LEE AND HIS ALLEGIANCE TO
HIS PRINCIPLED IDEALS.
IS MADE REAL IN THE HIS
ADVANCEMENT OF SOUND THE FUNDING
AND LEGISLATION FOR THE CHILDREN
OF CALIFORNIA.
MOREOVER HE HAS CONSISTENTLY
STOOD FOR THE RIGHTS OF WOMEN IN
THEIR ADVANCEMENT IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE.
AS ALREADY HAS BEEN NOTED WE
HAVE GROWING OR WOMEN'S CAUCUS.
TO TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE WOMEN
LEADERS ON THIS FLOOR.
AND WITH THAT --
WE HAVE SEEN THE SUPPORT RENDON
ON WE EVEN SEE IT TODAY WITH A
WHOLE CLUSTER OF WOMEN RIGHT
HERE IN THE SONORA IDEAL.
SO WITH THAT MEMBERS --
WE AND ALL OF YOU PLEASE JOIN ME
AND SOME REPORTING THE
NOMINATION FOR SPEAKER MISTER
ANTHONY RENDON ON THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SECOND THE
NOMINATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
MEMBERS I AM TWO IT JOINED HERE
TODAY -- BY --
MY FATHER AND ALONG SIDE WITH MY
NINETY YEAR OLD GRANDMOTHER.
WHO HAS LIVED IN SACRAMENTO FOR
A LONG PERIOD OF TIME TO WHICH
MY GRAPH OF ALSO WORKED NEARBY
OFFERING FATS AND SO I KNOW
THEY'RE EQUALLY DIVIDED AT TO BE
HERE?
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THE
NOMINATION OF ANTHONY RENDON AS
SPEAKER.
AS CHAIR OF THE LGBT LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS.
WE'VE A LOT OF FIGHTING TO DO.
SO.
AND NO.
LEADER IS AS FABULOUS.
AS OUR SPEAKER.
AND ENSURING THAT WE HAVE THE
BASIC FUNDAMENTALS OF A QUALITY
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND PARTICULARLY WHEN YOU SEE AN
ATTACK ON THE RECOGNITION OF ALL
WITHIN THE LGBT COMMUNITY.
SOMETIMES.
WE NEED A STRONG ALLY.
AND WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
RATES OF SUICIDE.
ARE THIS NOTION OF CONVERSION
THERAPY.
SPEAKER RENDON HAS CHAMPION
THESE ISSUES OF EQUALITY FOR ALL
OF US.
AT THE SAME TIME RECOGNIZING.
THAT WE MUST BE MAGNANIMOUS.
AND BUILDING BRIDGES.
DEMONSTRATING LOVE. TO JUST WHY
WE SAW AFTER THIS ELECTION
[inaudible]
A VERY.
HUMBLE APPROACH TO GOVERNANCE
AND INSURING THAT WE HAVE ALL
VOICES COLLECTIVELY.
TOGETHER AT THIS TABLE.
IN FACT THEY'RE EVEN THE TIME TO
WHICH HE KNEW THINGS BEFORE I
KNEW.
OF ACTIVITIES IN THE LGBT
COMMUNITY.
HE HAD CALLED AND SAID.
WHEN ARE WE RECOGNIZING THE PALM
SPRINGS CITY COUNCIL?
ON THREE CITY COUNCIL MADE
HISTORY IN THE UNITED STATES BY
HAVING THE ALL LGBT CITY COUNCIL
AND UNITED STATES THAT'S HERE AT
HOME IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND IT WAS SPEAKER RENDON WHO
SAID WE MUST HONOR AND RECOGNIZE.
GIVEN THE IMPORTANCE OF THE WORK
THAT WE HAVE AHEAD OF US.
TODAY'S THAT TYPE OF INDIVIDUAL.
WELL LEAST TO MY KNOWLEDGE.
DOES NOT PERSONALLY IDENTIFY AS
LGBT [inaudible]
HI ANY.
BUT THAT IS THE COMMITTEE THAT
WE LIVE IN.
AND HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT WE ARE
STRONGER TOGETHER.
AND MEMBERS WITH THAT I TO
SECOND THE NOMINATION OF ANTHONY
RENDON AS SPEAKER OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SECOND THE
NOMINATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS I'M
PROUD TO SECOND THE NOMINATION
FOR THE OFFICE OF SPEAKER OF THE
ASSEMBLY.
OUR FRIEND AND COLLEAGUE AND
LEADER ANTHONY RENDON.
IS CAPABLE LEADERSHIP HAS
RESULTED IN AN LAST FALL.
AND CIVIL.
MASSIVE AND PRODUCTIVE.
LET ME TELL YOU ABOUT THINGS
LOOK FROM WHERE I STAND AS THE
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE BEEN
SUPPORTED AND EMPOWERED.
BY THE SPEAKER TO RUN THE
COMMITTEE AND NOT JUST BE A
RUBBER STAMP.
AS A MEMBER OF COMMITTEES I'VE
BEEN PART OF A THOROUGH AND OPEN
PROCESS THAT LETS US DIG DEEP
INTO THE ISSUES.
AS A REPRESENTATIVE OF THE FORTY
FOURTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT I KNOW
THAT THE SPEAKER RESPECTS MY
VOTES.
THAT I CAST FROM MY DISTRICT AND
FOR MY CONSCIENCE.
AND I KNOW THAT I'M NOT ALONE I
BELIEVE EVERY RETURNING MEMBER
REGARDLESS OF PARTY OR LENGTH OF
SERVICE COULD EASILY ASSOCIATE
THEMSELVES WITH MY REMARKS. TO
THE NEW MEMBERS HERE TODAY.
WE WELCOME YOU AND WE WANT YOU
TO KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO
HAVE A SPEAKER WHO MAKES IT
POSSIBLE FOR EACH OF US TO WORK
ON BEHALF OF OUR CONSTITUENTS
AND ALL OF CALIFORNIA.
STICKING WITH THE PROVEN
RESPONSIBLE AND RESPONSIVE
LEADERSHIP OF ANTHONY RENDON IS
THE BEST WAY I KNOW TO ENSURE
OUR FUTURE SUCCESS.
IT IS AN HONOR.
TO SECOND TO THE NOMINATION OF
ANTHONY RENDON FOR THE OFFICE OF
SPEAKER OF THE ASSEMBLY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRAZIER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
I ALSO RISE TODAY TO SECOND THE
NOMINATION OF MY FRIEND AND
BROTHER.
ANTHONY RENDON. TO SERVICES
SPEAKER THIS BODY [inaudible]
CALLING.
I CAN'T THINK OF A BETTER PERSON
TO LEAD US INTO THIS NEW SESSION
WITH SO MANY NEW MEMBERS.
AND A NEW GOVERNOR.
THE PEOPLE OF THIS GREAT STATE
HAVE ENTRUSTED US WITH NEW SUPER
MAJORITIES IN BOTH HOUSES.
AND WITH THAT.
COMES GREAT RESPONSIBILITY.
OR SPEAKER HAS TIME AND TIME
AGAIN PROVEN THIS ABILITY TO
LEAD.
HE HAS BEEN CRUCIAL TO THE
SUCCESS OF THIS BODY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE OF HIS LEADERSHIP WE
PASSED SB.
ONE VOTERS SOUNDLY UP HELD LAST
MONTH.
WHICH CREATED SIXTY EIGHT
THOUSAND JOBS IN CALIFORNIA.
HIS LEADERSHIP PHILOSOPHY IS TO
EMPOWER MEMBERS AND COMMITTEE
CHAIRS.
I AM GRATEFUL TO SPEAKER RENDON
FOR ESTABLISHING THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
AND ALLOWING ME TO CHAPTER THIS
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS.
HE EMBRACES AND UNDERSTANDS THAT
EACH OF US HAS PERSONAL PASSIONS.
IT IS SUPPORT IS UNWAVERING. FOR
WHICH I AM IN THE THIRD
INTERNALLY.
ABSOLUTELY GRATEFUL.
I NOR SPEAKERS COMMITTED AND
WILL HE WILL HELP ACCOMPLISH
GREAT THINGS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
THEREFORE IT IS MY DISTINCT
HONOR. TO SECOND THE NOMINATION.
A SPEAKER ANTHONY RENDON.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER.
ARE THERE ANY FURTHER
NOMINATIONS FOR THE OFFICE OF
SPEAKER OF THE ASSEMBLY.
HEARING NO FURTHER NOMINATIONS
NOMINATIONS ARE NOW CLOSED.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE
RULES AND PRESIDENT.
REQUIRING A RECORDED ROLL CALL
VOTE.
WILL BE SUSPENDED TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ANTHONY RENDON.
TO BE ELECTED SPEAKER OF THE
ASSEMBLY FOR THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWENTY REGULAR SESSION.
BY A VOICE VOTE.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR OF ELECTING
ANTHONY RENDON SPEAKER THE OF
THE ASSEMBLY SIGNIFY BY THE
USUAL SIDE OF BY.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE EYES HAVE IT CONGRATULATIONS
SPEAKER RENDON
I AM A POINTING
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS TO ESCORT
THE SPEAKER ELECT.
AND HIS WIFE ANNE LAMB. TO THE
ROSTRUM WITH THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS RETIRED TO THE REAR OF
THE CHAMBER.
AS YOUR NAME IS CALL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS.
POWER QUE HAN.
BURNER FOR THAT [inaudible]
THREE NORRIS [inaudible]
ROMMEL'S [inaudible]
ROBERT REAVIS [inaudible]
SUBMIT [inaudible]
WAKES.
AND TYLER DE.
PLEASE RETIRED TO THE REAR OF
THE CHAMBERS. TO ESCORT THE
SPEAKER TO THE ROSTRUM.
THE OATH OF OFFICE WILL BE
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA.
ATTORNEY GENERAL HOBBY ERR BUT
SERRA
.
PLEASE IS FOR THE SPEAKER ELECT.
TO THE ROSTER
[inaudible]
OKAY
.
SB RAISE YOUR RIGHT HAND.
REPEAT AFTER ME.
HI YOUR NAME I HAVE A RENDON'S.
THOMAS WHERE DO SOLEMNLY SWEAR.
THAT I WILL SUPPORT AND DEFEND
THE CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES.
AND THE CONSTITUTION FOR THE
CITY CALIFORNIA THE CONSTITUTION
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AGAINST ALL ENEMIES FOREIGN AND
DOMESTIC AGAINST ALL ENEMIES
FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC.
THAT I WILL BEAR TRUE FAITH AND
ALLEGIANCE FEDERAL VERY TRUE
FAITH AND ALLEGIANCE TO THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES OF THE CONSTITUTION A
NIGHT STATES FROM THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE CONSTITUTION OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT I TAKE THIS OBLIGATION
FREELY THAT I TAKE THIS
OBLIGATION FREELY WITHOUT ANY
MENTAL RESERVATION WITHOUT ANY
MEASURE MENTAL RESERVATION OR
PURPOSE OF EVASION OR PURPOSE OF
EVASION.
AND THAT I WILL WELL AND
FAITHFULLY AND THAT I WILL WELL
AND FAITHFULLY.
DISCHARGE THE DUTIES DISCHARGE
THE DUTIES.
UPON WHICH I'M ABOUT TO ENTER OF
OUR WHICH I'M ABOUT.
TO GRADUATE
[inaudible]
YEAH WE DO ANYTHING ELSE LET US
REFLECT ON CALIFORNIA'S RECENT.
HORRENDOUS FIRES.
NO MATTER WHAT THE SIZE OF THE
FIRE.
IT IS THE BIGGEST EVENTS IN
EVERY LIFE IT TOUCHES.
LET US THINK OF THOSE OF US EVEN
AS THEY COME TO BE SWORN IN.
WHO ARE PREOCCUPIED WITH CARING
FOR THE PEOPLE IN THEIR
DISTRICTS?
SINCE WE RECESSED AT THE
BEGINNING OF AUGUST NEW FIRES
HAVE BROKEN OUT IN THE LEVIN
COUNTIES.
LISTED CHRONOLOGICALLY THEY ARE
[inaudible]
PLACERVILLE [inaudible]
MONACO [inaudible]
TRINITY [inaudible]
SHASTA [inaudible]
NAPA.
LOS ANGELES.
TULARE [inaudible]
SOLANA [inaudible] TO HAMMER
[inaudible]
VIEW.
AND VENTURA COUNTIES.
OUR MEMBERS ARE WORRYING ABOUT
THOSE WHO LOST THEIR LIVES.
THOSE WHO LOST THEIR HOMES.
AND THOSE WHO SHOWED
EXTRAORDINARY HEROISM.
WEATHER WAS FIREFIGHTERS
[inaudible]
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
MEDICAL PERSONNEL.
OR THE MANY MANY VOLUNTEERS
PROVIDING THE AID TO THE
DISPLACED.
THIS ALSO APPLIES TO THE LIVES
LOST IN GUN.
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
SPECIALLY THOSE TAKEN IN THE
RECENT TRAGEDY OF THOUSAND OAKS.THAT IS ALL GO BEYOND THE USUAL
MOMENT OF SILENCE.
AND USE THIS MOMENT TO CONSIDER
WHAT WE ARE HERE.
FOR WHICH IS TO MAKE LIFE BETTER
FOR EVERY CALIFORNIA.
LET'S THINK ABOUT WHAT WE WILL
DO IN THE NEXT TWO YEARS.
A MOMENT'S SILENCE PLEASE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BEING CHOSEN TO AGAIN SERVICE
SPEAKER IS ALL THE MORE AN HONOR.
BECAUSE IT AS A TACIT KNOWLEDGE
MINT OF WHAT WE HAVE DONE HERE.
IN THE ASSEMBLY.
MY GOAL WAS TO USE THIS OFFICE
FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. TO DO THAT I AIM TO
WORK TO MAKE IT POSSIBLE. FOR
ALL OF YOU TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
I BELIEVE WE HAVE BEEN
EXCEPTIONALLY SUCCESSFUL UP TO
NOW.
MAKING THINGS BETTER FOR
CALIFORNIANS INCLUDED INCLUDES
WRITING HISTORIC WRONGS AND
EXPANDING ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY.
THAT'S WHAT WE DID BY TACKLING
BAIL REFORM TO ENSURE THAT NO
ONE STAYS IN JAIL.
JUST BECAUSE THEY'RE POOR.
THAT'S WHAT WE DID IN PROVIDING
FARM WORKER OVERTIME. TO THOSE
WHO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE FOOD
ON OUR TABLE.
AND IT'S WHAT WE DID WHEN WE
EXPANDED THE EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT AND RAISE THE MINIMUM
WAGE TO MAKE SURE THAT FAMILIES
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO PUT FOOD
ON THEIR TABLES.
WE ALSO FOUND A WAY TO PAY FOR
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT EVERY CALIFORNIA RELIES ON
AND WE DID IT WITHOUT GOING INTO
DEBT.
WHEN THEY ELECTED AS LAST MONTH?
CALIFORNIA'S ALSO SHOWED THAT
THEY SAW THROUGH THIS CYNICAL
CAMPAIGN THAT WAS AS MUCH ABOUT
SNAKE OIL.
AS A WAS ABOUT THE GAS TAX.
WE HAVE TAKEN MAJOR STEPS TO
CREATE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND INUNDATED IN OUR USE OF CAP
AND TRADE TO COUNTERACT CLIMATE
CHANGE AND BRING ABOUT
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
YEAR AFTER YEAR THE ASSEMBLY HAS
PUT TOGETHER IN APPROVED BUDGETS
THAT EXPAND WHAT WE PROVIDE FOR
CALIFORNIANS IN A WAY THAT PLANS
FOR THE FUTURE.
BOTH GOOD.
AND BAD.
WE HAVE INVESTED IN EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION K. THROUGH
TWELVE COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
THAT'S BUILDING FOR A STRONGER
FUTURE.
AT THE SAME TIME WE HAVE SET
ASIDE RECORD RESERVES AS A
CUSHION AGAINST BAD TIMES AND
MAKE GOVERNMENT MORE ACCOUNTABLE
FOR WHAT THEY ARE DEALING WITH
TAXPAYER DOLLARS AS WE PUSH FOR
WITH THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION.
AND THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
THE THREAD THAT RUNS THROUGH ALL
OF THESE POLICY VICTORIES IS
MAKING THINGS BETTER FOR THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
JUST THAT ONE GOAL.
LET'S LEAVE OUR STATE BETTER
THAN WHEN WE FOUND IT.
OVER THE LAST SIX YEARS I'VE
LEARNED SOMETHING IMPORTANT.
WORKING ON BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA LEADS TO SUCCESS.
AND THOSE SUCCESSES ARE REWARDED.
BY THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
JUST MAKING THINGS BETTER IS IS
REALLY.
WHY ALL OF YOU ARE HERE BOTH YOU
COMMERCE?
AND THOSE WHO ARE RETURNING.
WE HAVE MADE THINGS BETTER IN
CALIFORNIA SAID THAT THEY THE
CALIFORNIA VOTERS SAID THEY
LIKED WHAT WE'RE DOING.
I WANT TO LOOK BACK FOR A SECOND.
LOOK BACK TO THE SWEARING IN TWO
YEARS AGO.
WHEN THE OUTLOOK WAS SOMEWHAT
DIFFERENT?
I KNEW THEN THAT WE ARE ENTERING
PERILOUS TERRITORY.
MY WORST FEARS HAVE NOT YET
MATERIALIZED WE'VE IT OR NOT.
BUT THE FEDERAL REALITY HAS BEEN
QUITE BAD ENOUGH.
IN THE LAST MONTH WE HAVE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
HEAPING BLAME ON CALIFORNIA A
STATE THAT IS SUFFERING ITS
WORST FIRE DISASTER EVER.
I WOULD NOT HAVE IMAGINED.
THAT THE PRESIDENT WOULD NEGLECT
A TO A HEAVILY POPULATED ISLAND
DECIMATED BY HURRICANE.
AND YET SEND TROOPS TO LONELY
OUT LONELY BORDER OUTPOSTS TO DO
NOTHING.
BUT POSTURE. TWO YEARS AGO
BEFORE THAT MAN EVEN TOOK OFFICE
I SAID CALIFORNIA MUST BE
DEFIANT WHENEVER JUSTICE
FAIRNESS AND RIGHTS JUSTICE
REQUIRE A WE HAVE BACK THOSE
ACTIONS UP WITH WORDS.
WE HAVE BEEN AGGRESSIVE ON
POVERTY WE'VE BEEN AGGRESSIVE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ON BAIL
REFORM ON CIVIL RIGHTS AND WE'VE
BEEN AGGRESSIVE ON EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION.
THE ASSEMBLY HAS NOT BEEN ALONE
IN THIS.
WE'VE BEEN JOINED BY THE
GOVERNOR.
THE SENATE.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THE SECRETARY OF STATE AND SO
MANY.
BUT NOBODY NOBODY BELIEVES THAT
WE'RE DONE WITH OUR WORK.
IF WE HAD ALL THE IF WE HAD DONE
ALL THERE IS TO BE DO IT DONE.
THERE BE NO NEED TO BE SWORN IN
TODAY WE CAN JUST GO HOME.
MOVE WE'RE NOT GOING OUT.
WE TEND TO SPEND THE NEXT TWO
YEARS CONTINUING TO MAKE THINGS
BETTER FOR CALIFORNIANS.
THOSE OF US WHO ARE MEMBERS OF
ETHNIC MINORITIES OR WOMEN ARE
PART OF THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY.
I HAVE AN ANNOUNCEMENT FOR OF A
LATER -- I'M
SURE THAT WHERE.
YOU'RE KIDDING --
THE CAUCUS SEVEN YEAH.
THOSE IF YOU ARE PART OF OF
THOSE COMMUNITIES MAY FIND OUR
TASK ESPECIALLY SIGNIFICANT
BECAUSE HISTORICALLY WE FELT
FROZEN OUT OF THE HALLS OF
DECISION MAKING.
BUT NOW WE'RE HERE.
AND OUR NUMBERS ARE GROWING.
LAST YEAR WAS THE FIRST IN WHICH
THE MAJORITY OF ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
BELONGED TO ETHNIC MINORITIES.
AND THIS YEAR AS AS HAS BEEN
STATED.
THE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS HAS TWENTY
ONE WOMEN.
THAT'S AS MANY AS ANY MAJORITY
CAUCUS IN HISTORY AND NEARLY
TWICE AS MANY WOMEN.
AS WHEN I BECAME SPEAKER.
EACH OF OUR NEW COLLEAGUES HAS
AN INSPIRING LIFE STORY LEADING
TO THEIR ARRIVAL IN THE ASSEMBLY.
BUFFY WORKS GREW UP IN A MOBILE
HOME IN PLASTER COUNTY.
SHE WENT ON TO BE AN ANTI WAR
ORGANIZER AND A WHITE HOUSE
STAFFER HOPPING PRESIDENT OBAMA.
PASSED THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT.
REBEKAH MARK A HAND IS THE
GRANDDAUGHTER OF REFUGEES WHO
CAME TO UNITED STATES TO ESCAPE
THE HOLOCAUST.
THEIR REFUGEE EXPERIENCE
INSPIRED REBEKAH TO HELP OTHER
IMMIGRANTS.
INCLUDING WORKING TO AID THOSE
WHO'VE BEEN AFFECTED BY THE JUST
TRAVEL AROUND [inaudible]
ROBERT REAVIS.
RUBBER GREW UP AND FARM WORKER
HOUSING CARED FOR BY A SINGLE
MOTHER.
AND GRANDPARENTS WHO IMMIGRATED
FROM MEXICO TO SAN BENITO COUNTY.
HE OVERCAME A DISABILITY THROUGH
HIS MOTHER'S COMMITMENT. TO USE
HER SAVINGS FOR HIS SPEECH
IMPEDIMENT.
CHRISTY SMITH WAS BORN OVERSEAS
WHILE HER FATHER WAS IN THE
MILITARY.
SHE STARTED WORKING TO BETTER
THE SITUATION OF WORKERS EARLY
ON BEING THE YOUNGEST LABOR
LEADER TO NEGOTIATE A CONTRACT
AT COLLEGE OF THE CANYONS.
JAMES RAMEAU'S THE FIRST NATIVE
AMERICAN ELECTED TO THE SAMPLE
TO DO YOU KNOW COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
THE FIRST NATIVE AMERICAN
APPOINTED TO THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION BY GOVERNOR BROWN.
AND TODAY HE IS NOW THE FIRST
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATOR BORN ON
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBAL TERRITORY
.
KILEY PETER YOURS HAS ALWAYS HAD
HER EYES ON THE LARGER WORLD
THAT SHE MET HER HUSBAND CALLING
IN SOUTH AFRICA.
AND HIS FIRST OPPORTUNITY TO
VOTE AS AMERICAN AFTER BECAME IT
TO BECOMING A CITIZEN.
LAST YEAR INCLUDING VOTED
INCLUDED VOTING [inaudible]
MISTY SAID.
TYLER DEEPS FAMILY RELIED ON
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE WHEN THEY
IMMIGRATED FROM VIETNAM BUT THEY
PERSISTED TO SEE HAVE BECOME THE
FIRST IN HIS FAMILY TO GO TO
COLLEGE IN THE US.
HE ACQUIRED A PASSION FOR PUBLIC
SERVICE AND WAS ELECTED TO
OFFICE AT TWENTY THREE TASHA
BURNER HORVATH ALSO EMBODIES
CALIFORNIA'S MULTICULTURAL
OUTLOOK.
HAVING LIVED IN EUROPE WHERE SHE
MET HER HUSBAND AND WHERE THEY
HAVE THEIR TWO CHILDREN.
THE BILINGUAL FAMILY SPEAKS
ENGLISH AND GERMAN AT HOME.
THIS IS ONE OF THE SMALLEST NEW
CLASSES WE'VE SEEN.
BUT I KNOW THIS GROUP IS NOT
SMALL WHEN IT COMES TO ENERGY.
AND WHEN IT COMES TO IDEAS.
WE WELCOME THEIR TALENTS AND
ENTHUSIASM BECAUSE THE NEEDS ARE
URGENT.
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN IS KNOWN
FOR TALKING ABOUT HOW DIRE THE
CLIMATE SITUATION IS IT IS DIRE.
WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH THAT NOW.
THE WILDFIRES HAVE ADDED AN
EXCLAMATION POINT TO THAT BUT
THEY ALSO BRING QUESTION MARKS
ON SHORT TERM SAFETY.
AND ENERGY SECURITY.
WE DO NOT HAVE THE LUXURY OF
IGNORING THE FIRES.
WILDFIRES IN FACT INJECT FEAR
AND PRESENT DANGERS TO NEARLY
EVERY CALIFORNIANS BUT LET ME
REMIND YOU THAT SOME
CALIFORNIANS HAVE LESS
PROTECTION THAN OTHERS.
GLANCES IN CLASSES WERE CANCELED
AT UNIVERSITIES DUE TO SMOKE
FROM THE CAMPFIRE.
BUSINESSES WERE CLOSED IN
CHILDREN WERE KEPT INDOORS.
BUT THE HOMELESS HAVE NO CHOICE
BUT TO SPEND ALL DAY READING
TOXIC AIR FROM THE FIRE.
WE HAVE MUCH MORE TO DO ON
HOUSING AND WE HAVE MORE TO DO
AND ECONOMIC INJUSTICE BECAUSE
ECONOMIC INJUSTICE IS A FACTOR.
IN NEARLY EVERYTHING WE WORK ON
WHETHER WE TALK ABOUT IT OR NOT.
AND I'LL COME BACK TO THAT IN A
MOMENT.
USUALLY I LIKE TO TALK ABOUT
CALIFORNIA EXCEPTIONALISM.
I HAVE THE LUXURY OF TALKING
ABOUT IT STATE THAT HAS LONG
BEEN WELCOMING OF IT OF
IMMIGRANTS.
AND HAS BEEN RICHER BECAUSE OF
IT.
I CAN TALK ABOUT UNPARALLELED
NATURAL RESOURCES THE DRAW THE
WORLD TO OUR BEACHES AND OUR
MOUNTAINS.
I CAN TALK ABOUT AN ECONOMY THE
KEEP INNOVATING FROM THE DAYS OF
MOVIES AND AEROSPACE. TO PRESENT
DAY OF THE STATE WIDE WINE
COUNTRY AND SILICON DREAMS.
I CAN TALK ABOUT ARTISTIC
ACHIEVEMENT A NINETY MILLION
DOLLAR DAVID HOCKNEY PAINTING
RECENTLY SET AT AUCTION A RECORD.
AND IT DOES EVERYTHING TO ITS
CALIFORNIA SETTING.
WHEN I MODERATED A PANEL AT UCLA
EARLIER THIS YEAR ANOTHER
EXCEPTIONAL ARTIST THE THEATER
DIRECTOR PETER SALAS BROUGHT ME
DOWN TO EARTH?
WHEN WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
CALIFORNIA EXCEPTIONALISM?
PETER SAID YOU KNOW WHAT MAKES
CALIFORNIA EXCEPTIONAL.
WE PUT PEOPLE IN PRISON AT A
RATE HIGHER THAN ANY COUNTRY IN
THE WORLD INCLUDING CHINA.
AND RUSSIA.
WHAT MAKES US EXCEPTIONAL IS WE
HAVE A BIGGER HOMELESS
POPULATION THAN ANYWHERE ELSE?
WHAT MAKES US EXCEPTIONAL AS WE
HAVE A HUGE WATER CRISIS THAT IS
BEING LARGELY IGNORED?
HOW CAN WE BE PROUD OF OUR
VIBRANT TACK ECONOMY THE ENVY OF
THE WORLD?
IF THE UNDENIABLY BRILLIANT
MINDS OF THAT SECTOR ARE USED
ONLY TO GENERATE HUGE PERSONAL
WEALTH FOR A FEW.
AND MISERY FOR OTHERS.
WE MUST USE OUR TECHNOLOGICAL
RESOURCES TO IMPROVE THE LIVES
OF WORKERS AS WELL AS INVESTORS
FOR THE HOMELESS AS WELL AS FOR
TOURISTS AND THE HOMEOWNERS WITH
EXTRA ROOMS TO RENT OUT.
WE CAN NOT MAKE HOUSING
AFFORDABLE FOR THE MASSES WHEN
THE 1% EARNING HUNDREDS AND
THOUSANDS OF TIMES THE AVERAGE
WORKER.
AND WE CAN NOT IMPROVE THE LIVES
OF PEOPLE LIVING PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK --
FACE PREDATORY LENDERS CHARGING
OUT READ JUST INTEREST RATES
WHILE MASSIVE CORPORATIONS GET
PUBLIC HANDOUTS IN THE HOPES OF
TRICKLE DOWN BENEFITS THAT WE
ALL KNOW WILL NEVER REACH PEOPLE
ON THE BOTTOM.
THESE ARE BI PARTISAN CHALLENGES
THAT REQUIRE BIPARTISAN
SOLUTIONS.
I BELIEVE THAT THE REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS HAS A ROLE IN MAKING
CALIFORNIA BETTER.
MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MARIE WALDRON HAS ALREADY SERVED
WELL ON BIPARTISAN COMMITTEES.
DEALING WITH SEXUAL HARASSMENT
AND HEALTH CARE FINANCING.
AND HER EXPERIENCE WILL SERVE AS
WELL AS SHE TAKES OVER AS
REPUBLICAN LEADER.
WE WILL ALSO WORK TOWARD A
BETTER CALIFORNIA IN IN
COOPERATION WITH THE SENATE AND
THE GOVERNOR I HAVE SOME HISTORY
WITH THE SENATE PRO TEM LEADER
AND TO GOOD HISTORY.
AND I SAT DOWN A FEW TIMES OF
THE GOVERNOR ELECT AND THEY'VE
BEEN GOOD TALKS.
PRO TEN MACINNES PER TEN
MACINNES AND GOVERNOR LIKE NEW
SEVEN MYSELF HAVE VERY SIMILAR
VALUES SIMILAR GOALS AND SIMILAR
PRIORITIES. TO REACH THOSE GOALS
THOUGH IT WILL TAKE WHAT EACH OF
US HAS LEARNED.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH BOTH OF THEM.
BUT MOSTLY WILL DEPEND ON THE
KNOWLEDGE IN THIS ROOM.
SO THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY.
TO PUT OUR FULL SHOULDER TO THE
WHEEL.
BECAUSE IT'S URGENT.
AND IT WILL TAKE ALL OF US TO DO
IT.
EVERYONE HAS COME HERE WITH
IDEAS.
AND AB ONE WILL CROSS THE DESK
BEFORE I CROSSED THE THRESHOLD
TO LEAVE THE BUILDING TODAY.
DOZENS MORE WILL BE FOLLOWED
HUNDRED STAFF SINCE.
WILL FOLLOW.
I'VE TALKED ABOUT THE HUGE
CHALLENGES BUT I HAVE HUGE HOPES.
TO POST THAT I KNOW WE CAN FILL
FILL.
WE CAN ADDRESS THE HUGE ECONOMIC
CHALLENGES THAT FACE
CALIFORNIA'S YOU NEED HOUSING.
WHO NEED HEALTH CARE WE NEED
EDUCATION FOR THEIR YOUNGEST
CHILDREN?
AND FOR THEIR OLDEST.
WE CAN CONTINUE FIGHTING FOR THE
RIGHTS OF WORKING PEOPLE
IMMIGRANTS AND ANYONE WHO'S
THREATEN THE BIAS. TO THAT WE
HAVE A NEW RESOURCE AT OUR
DISPOSAL [inaudible]
EXPERIENCE.
THE TERM LIMIT CHANGES OF TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE MEAN THAT THE
CLASS ELECTED IN THAT YEAR MY
CLASS.
HAS BEEN HERE SIX YEARS I CAN BE
HERE FOR SIX YEARS MORE.
EVERYONE OF YOU EVERYONE OF YOU
FROM THOSE OF MY CLASS TO THOSE
TAKING THE OATH OF OFFICE FOR
THE FIRST DOWN TIME.
ARE NOW PART OF THE DELIVERED OF
BODY WITH MORE YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE THAN ANY SITTING
ASSEMBLY IN TWO DECADES.
WE NEED THAT EXPERIENCE WE WILL
USE THAT EXPERIENCE.
IF WE DO THE NEXT TWO YEARS WILL
BE A GREAT EXPERIENCE FOR US.
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
THANK YOU
.
WE ARE JOINED BY MANY ESTEEMED
GUESTS TODAY.
PLEASE WELCOME THE CAT
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR AND GOVERNOR
ELECT GAVIN NEWSOM
.
PLEASE WELCOME ATTORNEY GENERAL
HAVE YOU EVER SERRA.
PLEASE WELCOME INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER DAVE JONES.
PLEASE WELCOME TREASURER ELECT
FIONA MARK.
PLEASE WELCOME SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION ELECT TONY
THURMOND
.
WELCOME BACK TONY.
PLEASE WELCOME THE STATE
TREASURER JOHN CHIANG.
PLEASE WELCOME OUR LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR ELECT A LANEY COOK
COULD NOT ONLY THIS.
I LEARNED OUR TO SAY THE SUPREME
COURT JUSTICES NAME SO --
WE'RE GOOD.
OKAY WE'RE GETTING --
MY SPECIAL GUESTS PLEASE WELCOME
MY SPECIAL GUEST MY WIFE ANY
LAMB
.
PLEASE WELCOME MY PARENTS THEY
HAVE THEIR NAMES WRITTEN HERE IS
JUST MOM AND DAD.
TOM LAURIA RENDON.
AND MY IN LAWS FROM THE LAMP
FAMILY SITTING IN THE REAR.
WE ALSO WELCOME FORMER MEMBERS
THE LEGISLATURE OTHER
DISTINGUISHED PUBLIC OFFICIALS
FAMILY AND SPECIAL GUESTS WHO
HAVE JOINED US TODAY.
OUR NEXT ORDER OF BUSINESS IS
THE APPOINTMENT OF THE SPEAKER
PRO TEM.
I AM APPOINTING KEVIN MULLIN OF
THE TWENTY SECONDS ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT TO THIS OFFICE AND
SELECT AND A SELECT COMMITTEE TO
ESCORT HIM TO THE ROSTER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PRO TEM
DESIGNATE MULLIN IN THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERS SHOULD RETIRE
TO THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER
[inaudible]
MARIE WALDRON.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BERMAN
[inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE STONE.
AND TING
.
MR MULLIN WILL BE JOINED ESTATE
WILL BE JOINED TODAY BY HIS WIFE
JESSICA IS TWINS LIAM AND LAND
ON LANDON
[inaudible]
THE YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
WELL AS THEY HAVE TO RAISE YOUR
RIGHT HAND AND REPEAT AFTER ME.
I SPEAK YOUR NAME I KEVIN MULLIN
DO SOLEMNLY SWEAR DO SOLEMNLY
SWEAR THAT I WILL SUPPORT AND
DEFEND OUR SUPPORT FAN THE
CONSTITUTION AND UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTION THE UNITED STATES
AND THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AGAINST ALL ENEMIES FOREIGN AND
DOMESTIC AGAINST ALL ENEMIES
FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC.
THAT I WILL BEAR TRUE FAITH AND
ALLEGIANCE NOW BEAR TRUE FAITH
AND ALLEGIANCE TO THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES CONSTITUTION UNITED
STATES AND THE CONSTITUTION FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THAT I TAKE THIS OBLIGATION
FREELY I TAKE THIS OBLIGATION
FREELY WITHOUT ANY MENTAL
RESERVATION WITHOUT ANY MENTAL
RESERVATION OR PURPOSE OF
EVASION OR PURPOSE OF EVASION.
AND THAT I WILL WELL AND
FAITHFULLY THAT WILL WELL AND
FAITHFULLY DISCHARGE THE DUTIES
DISCHARGE THE DUTIES UPON WHICH
I'M ABOUT TO ENTER [inaudible]
GRADUATION
[inaudible]
GRADUATIONS RESTAURANT.
MEMBERS IF YOU'VE NOT YET
ACTIVATED THE VOTING MECHANISM
AT YOUR DESK.
PLEASE INSERT YOUR KEY.
AND TURN IT.
THERE ARE SEVERAL RESOLUTIONS AT
THE ASSEMBLY DESK AND COPIES ARE
ON YOUR DESK OUR NEXT ORDER OF
BUSINESS IS THE ADOPTION OF OUR
HOUSE RULES.
RULES CHAIR KEN COOLEY WILL
PRESENT HOUSE RESOLUTION NUMBER
ONE FOR THE PURPOSE OF THIRD
READING THE CLERK WILL NARRATE.
HOUSE RESOLUTION ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY RELATIVE
TO THE STANDING RULES OF THE
ASSEMBLY FOR THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY REGULAR SESSION.
MISTER COOLEY YOU MAY OPEN.
MISTER SPEAKER IS A NON OR ON
THE STATE TO JOIN MY COLLEAGUES
ON THIS FLOOR.
AND I THINK YOU SPECIFICALLY FOR
YOUR ARE MARKS REFLECTING UPON.
BUT I'VE ALWAYS FELT.
CALIFORNIA HAS BECOME THE MOST
IMPORTANT PARTICIPATORY
DEMOCRACY.
IN THE GLOW.
WE ENTER INTO THE PUBLIC'S WORK.
INDEED TO MY COLLEAGUES I WILL
TELL YOU THAT THE MOST IMPORTANT
LINE OF ANY BILL YOU AUTHOR.
IS NOT THE LINE WITH YOUR NAME
ON IT.
IT'S A LINE.
IT SAYS THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. TO AN ACTRESS
FALLS.
WE ARE CHARGED ON THIS FLOOR.
WITH KERRY FOR THE PUBLIC'S WORK.
THEY HAVE CONFIRMED THE MANTLE.
OF THE FUTURE.
UPON US ON THIS BY.
THIS IS WHY WHAT WE HAVE DONE TO
BROADEN.
THE CAPACITY OF CALIFORNIANS TO
VOTE.
ALIGNS WITH THIS BASIC IDEA IN
EVERY BILL.
THAT THE POWER WE KERRY.
IS THE POWER OF THE PEOPLE.
AND WHAT WE DO IN VOTING
[inaudible]
OPENING.
VOTING TO AS MANY CALIFORNIANS
AS WE MAY.
ALIGNS WITH THIS VERY
FUNDAMENTAL PREMISE.
OF A PARTICIPATORY DEMOCRACY.
AND THESE RULES.
HR ONE AS I BRING IT TO TODAY.
IS THE COMPANION. TO THIS NOTION.
BECAUSE AS THE SPEAKERS NOTED WE
HAVE THE MOST EXPERIENCED LAW
MAKING BODY.
THIS BEEN ON THIS CARPET IN MORE
THAN TWO DECADES.
AND THE HOUSE RULES ARE THE
FRAMEWORK WITHIN WHICH WE DO OUR
WORK.
AND SUPPORT THAT EMPOWER.
HOUSE RESOLUTION ONE ESTABLISHES
THE STANDARD RULES IN THE
ASSEMBLY. FOR THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY SESSION.
IT INCLUDES VARIOUS CHANGES TO
THE STANDARD RULES THAT WERE
PLACE IN THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN SESSION.
SOME OF THESE CHANGES INCLUDE.
REVISED IN THE NAME OF THE
PERSON COMMITTING. TO PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT. TO
REFLECT THE SENATE'S DESIGNATION.
TERRIFYING THE LEGISLATIVE
MEETINGS COMPLY WITH PROVISIONS
IN S. C. R..
THIRTY EIGHT ADOPTED LAST
SESSION.
RELATED TO RECORDING RULES.
THE MEASURE UPDATES LANGUAGE TO
MATCH LONG STANDING CUSTOMER
PRACTICE.
ROLE TO THE STANDARD OF BILLS
AND RESOLUTIONS AND COMMITTEES.
WHICH ARE COLLEAGUES.
DIRECT AS CHAIRS AND BUY SHARES.
EDIT A ROLL CALL REQUIREMENT FOR
JOINT RESOLUTIONS CONSIST OF THE
CURRENT CUSTOM.
AND PRACTICE OF THE ASSEMBLY.
VICE IN THE LANGUAGE THROUGHOUT
THE HOUSE RULES SO THE
REFERENCES TO GENDER.
ARE GENDER NEUTRAL.
REFLECTING THIS BODIES RESPECT.
FOR ALL STAFF AND MEMBERS AND
INDEED ALL CALIFORNIANS.
THE MEASURE INCLUDES A NUMBER OF
TECHNICAL REVISIONS.
THESE RULES WILL ENSURE THAT THE
ASSEMBLY OPERATE SMOOTHLY AND
EFFICIENTLY.
IN CARRYING OUT OUR RESPONSE WAS
ON THE CONSTITUTION. TO
EXERCISES POWER BEHALF OF THE
PEOPLE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I REQUEST YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY MISTER
OBERNOLTE.
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
OPPOSITION HR ONE COLLEAGUES
MANY OF THE RULE CHANGES WERE
CONSIDERING TODAY ARE ON
CONTROVERSIAL HOWEVER THERE IS
ONE THAT IS PARTICULARLY
TROUBLING.
AND THAT IS A CHANGE THAT ALLOWS
POLICY COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN DECIDE
ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS WHICH
BILLS TO GRANT POLICY COMMITTEE
HEARINGS.
TO THAT IS A VIOLATION OF LONG
STANDING CUSTOM AND PRACTICE IN
THIS CHAMBER OF ASSURING THAT
EVERY SINGLE BILL THAT'S
INTRODUCED GETS PAID HEARING.
CHAIRMAN UNDER THESE NEW RULES
WOULD HAVE THE POWER TO
ESSENTIALLY KILL A BILL BY
DENYING IT HEARING SINCE BILLS
REQUIRE HEARING TO MOVE FORWARD.
AND THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO DO
THIS NOT ONLY WITHOUT A HEARING.
BUT WITHOUT A VOTE OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE OR
WITHOUT ANY TESTIMONY FROM THE
PUBLIC.
THAT IS A VIOLATION NOT ONLY OF
THE LONG STANDING PRACTICE OF
THIS CHAMBER BUT ALSO OF THE
PRINCIPLES OF DEMOCRACY ITSELF I
URGE A NO VOTE.
ALL THE BAY HAVE A CEASE MISTER
COOLEY MAKE CLOTHES.
I REQUEST AN AYE VOTE ON THE
RULES TO SUPPORT OUR WORK IN THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
SESSION.
THANK YOU MISTER CROW WILL HAVE
TO WE WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE
ON HR ONE THIS RESOLUTION
REQUIRES. FORTY ONE VOTES THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE A MEMBER
SERVER DESERT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
OF THE DESERT ABOUT [inaudible]
THAT [inaudible]
YEAH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE ESERVER.
THE CLERK OF COURT WILL CLOSE
THE WRONG TALLY THE VOTE AYE
AYES FIFTY NINE KNOWS TWENTY THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MAJORITY LEADER CALDERON WILL
PRESENT HOUSE RESOLUTION. TO FOR
THE PURPOSE OF THIRD READING THE
TO HOUSE RESOLUTION TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RENDON RELATIVE
TO THE ELECTION OF OFFICERS OF
THE ASSEMBLY FOR THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY REGULAR SESSION.
MISTER CALDERON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I OFFER HOUSE RESOLUTION NUMBER
TWO ON BEHALF OF SPEAKER ANTHONY
RENDON TO DESIGNATE THE NON
MEMBER OFFICERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
FOR THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
TWENTY REGULAR SESSION.
THEY ARE EACH MISTER E. DOTSON
WILSON AS CHIEF CLERK MISTER
RICHARD DESMOND AS CHIEF
SERGEANT AT ARMS REVENUE PATTY
OSHA AS CHAPLAIN IN REVEREND BOB
OSHITA.
AS AN ALTERNATE CHAPLAIN.
IS THEIR ANY QUESTION OR DEBATE
ON HR.
TWO HAVING SEEN ON ALL DEBATE OF
A CEASE MISTER CALDERON LIKE
CLOSE.
MISTER CALDERON ASPIRIN AYE BUT
WE WILL TAKE ROLL CALL THE
NATURE TO THIS RESOLUTION
REQUIRES. FORTY ONE VOTES THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
ON MEMBERS OF THOSE IS THERE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK OF CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TELLING THE VOTE AYE AYES
SEVENTY NINE KNOWS ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MISTER WILSON MISTER DOES MEN
AND REFERENCE THAT PATTY AND BOB
OSHITA PLEASE COME FOR THE
ROSTER FOR THE OATH OF OFFICE.
A LOT OF WORK AND FOR MORE
.
MISTER WILSON.
DEVIN [inaudible]
REVEREND OSHITA.
I ASK THAT YOU EACH --
PLEASE REPEAT AFTER ME AND AS
YOU DO SO PLEASE RAISE YOUR
RIGHT HAND.
HI AND STATE YOUR NAME.
THIS.
DO SOLEMNLY SWEAR.
THAT I WILL SUPPORT AND DEFEND
IT I MEAN I WAS.
FOR THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES CONSTITUTION AND
NICE AND THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AGAINST ALL ENEMIES FOREIGN AND
DOMESTIC IT IS ALL AND IT MAKES
FOR INTERESTING.
THAT I WILL BEAR TRUE FAITH AND
ALLEGIANCE. TO THE CONSTITUTION
OF THE UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTION AND NEXT AND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
THE BUT I TAKE THIS OBLIGATION
FREELY.
WITHOUT ANY MENTAL RESERVATION.
RESERVATION.
OR PURPOSE OF EVASION OR PURPOSE
OF THE AND THAT I WILL WELL AND
FAITHFULLY.
WHEN A REAL ESTATE?
DISCHARGE THE DUTIES STARS THE
MEANS BY WHICH ARE ABOUT TO
ENTER ON WHICH I'M ABOUT.
CONGRATULATIONS FROM THE LEADER
CALDERON WILL PRESENT HOUSE
RESOLUTION NUMBER THREE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF THIRD READING HOUSE
RESOLUTION THREE THE CLERK WILL
READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RENDON RELATIVE
TO THE ORGANIZATION OF THE
ASSEMBLY FOR THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY REGULAR SESSION.
MISTER CALDERON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
HOUSE RESOLUTION NUMBER THREE IS
A ROUTINE HOUSEKEEPING
RESOLUTION WHICH DOES THE
FOLLOWING IT AUTHORIZES THE
RULES COMMITTEE CHIEF CLERK AND
SERGEANT AT ARMS. TO RECEIVE
WARRANTS FROM THE CONTROLLER TO
PAY MEMBERS OFFICERS AND STAFF
OF THE ASSEMBLY IT ALSO REQUIRES
A CHIEF CLERK TO PROVIDE COPIES
OF THE ASSEMBLY WEEKLY HISTORIES.
TO SPECIFIED GOVERNMENT OFFICES
AND ACCREDITED NEWSPAPER
REPRESENTATIVES AND SPECIFIES
THAT DURING THE ORGANIZATIONAL
RECESS NOPE NO BILL CAN BE
INTRODUCED AT THE DESK.
EXCEPT BY A PERSON DESIGNATED IN
WRITING BY THE MEMBER AND THE
DESIGNATION BE FILED WITH THE
CHIEF CLERK.
IS THERE ANY QUESTION OR DEBATE
ON HR.
THREE ALL THEY HAVING SIX
MISCARRIAGE LIKE CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON HR THREE WE WILL TAKE A ROLL
CALL VOTE ON HR THREE THE
RESOLUTION REQUIRES FORTY ONE
VOTES THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
OTHERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ON
THOSE VOTERS ALL THE TIRES
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT.
THE CLERK A CLOSE RUN TALLY THE
VOTE I SEVENTY NINE NOSE ZERO
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED THEIR
LETTERS AT THE DESK RELATIVE TO
THE LEADERSHIP OF THE DEMOCRATIC
AND REPUBLICAN CAUCUSES AND THE
NAMES OF MEMBERS WILL SERVE IN
THE CAPACITIES. TO WHICH THEY
WERE APPOINTED OR ELECTED IN THE
200-020-0020 REGULAR SESSION.
AT THE END OF THE SESSION TODAY
MEMBERS WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO INTRODUCE THEIR
FIRST LEGISLATIVE MEASURE.
I AM ORDERING THE DESK TO REMAIN
OPEN. FOR BILL INTRODUCTIONS
UNTIL FOUR PM TODAY DURING THE
EXAM ORGANIZATIONAL RECESS THE
BEST WILL BE OPEN FROM NINE AM
TO THREE PM.
DAILY UNTIL FRIDAY DECEMBER
FOURTEENTH FOR THE PURPOSE OF
BILL INTRODUCTIONS [inaudible]
YOURS
.
MEMBERS PLEASE DIRECT YOUR
ATTENTION TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DALLY MISTER DALLI YOU OF THE
FLOOR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I JUST WANTED --
TO ANNOUNCED THAT DID NOVEMBER.
WE SELECTED MARIE WALDRON TO BE
OUR REPUBLICAN LEADER AND I
WANTED -- TO
ANNOUNCED THAT PUBLICLY SHE
SERVED AS OUR FLOOR WEB AS MOST
OF YOU KNOW --
FOR MANY YEARS AND DID A GREAT
JOB THERE I WISH YOU WELL SHE'S
A WOMAN LEADING OUR CAUCUS AS
WE'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT WOMEN
TODAY SO I JUST WANTED.
TO GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO HER THANK
YOU FOR THE TIME I GOT TO WORK
WITH YOU LAST YEAR MISTER
SPEAKER.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO A
PRODUCTIVE.
SESSION THIS SESSION TO WANT TO
WELCOME MARIE AND
CONGRATULATIONS ON UNANIMOUS
VOTE FROM THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS
.
MEMBERS THERE IS A RESOLUTION AT
THE DEATHS RELATIVE TO THE
APPOINTMENT OF THE LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL.
WITHOUT OBJECTION AND WE WILL
MOVE TO THAT ITEM NOW.
THIS IS SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION NUMBER.
TWO SEPARATE.
A CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TO BY
SENATOR ROBB RELATIVE TO THE
SELECTION OF THE LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
AND MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN.
ON SCR.
TWO MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBER
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NUMBER TWO IS RELATIVE TO THE
SELECTION OF DIANNE F. BOYER
VINE AS THE LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL
CALIFORNIA.
DIANNE BORE VINE HAS SERVED AS A
LOOK AT THE LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL
SINCE JUNE SIXTH.
TWO THOUSAND TO THE LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL OVERSEES A STAFF OF FIVE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY EMPLOYEES WHO
PROVIDE EXPERT NONPARTISAN LEGAL
AND TECHNICAL SERVICES TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
DEBATE ON S. C. R..
TO SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MISTER CALDERON YOU MAY CLOSE WE
WISH.
WE WILL MOVE TO A VOTE ON S. C.
R. TO THIS IS A ROLL CALL
RESOLUTION REQUIRES.
FORTY ONE OR CALL THE ROLL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS OUT OF OUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE --
DESIRABLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF A RESERVE A WELL.
CLOSER ALL TELL ABOUT I SEVEN
NINE NO.
ZERO THAT RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
[inaudible]
YEAH.
MEMBERS I RECOGNIZE A DELEGATION
FROM THE SENATE.
IT HAS ARRIVED IN THE REAR OF
THE CHAMBER TO INFORM US THAT
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE HAS
ORGANIZED. FOR THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY REGULAR
SESSION.
I'D LIKE TO EXTEND OUR THANKS TO
SENATOR NANCY SKINNER.
AS WELL AS SENATOR BILL MINING
MAJORITY LEADER MINING THANK YOU
BOTH. FOR JOINING US ON THE
FLOOR.
MEMBERS I BELIEVE WE HAVE
COMPLETED THE ORGANIZATIONAL
TASKS FOR THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY REGULAR SESSION.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS UPON A GERMAN OF
SESSION TODAY WE WILL BEGIN OUR
ORGANIZATIONAL RECESS.
THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS MONDAY JANUARY SEVENTH
TWENTY NINETEEN FLOOR SESSION IS
AT ONE PM.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN MISTER
CALDERON MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY JANUARY
SEVENTH TWENTY NINETEEN AT ONE
PM.
AND THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED